did you uh did you see what kat williams
said about canceled culture this weekend
i didn't see the whole thing but i heard
him
a little bit i saw the snippet yeah yeah
basically the gist
is that he uh he basically said that
cancel culture
uh doesn't really exist that there's not
really like a culture of cancellation
and he uses this quote if you ask all
the people that didn't make it in the
nba if you ask them if you just lower
the goal down another foot
uh they would all tell you that they
would make it nobody likes the out of
bounds but the out of bounds got to be
there
or else you'll run into the stands no
one's no one likes the speed limit
but it's got to be there no one likes to
shoulder the road but it's got to be
there and if you ask people uh
i don't know who we got canceled that we
wish we had back who are they
if it's done for the reason it's done
for and it helped what helped that's all
is going to happen
uh blah blah blah and basically he says
that people back in the day when they
could say whatever they want maybe they
weren't all that funny anyway
i don't disagree with a lot of what he
said um i think
there's a more nuanced way to say it i
think you also should be allowed to if
your intention is to try to be funny and
you [ __ ] up
you should be allowed to try again uh i
also think it's ironic that
so many people were rushing to celebrate
this guy and how perfectly he said it
and we're neglecting the fact that uh he
fought and lost to a 17 year old
kid got the [ __ ] kicked out of him and
also went on a
to quote the media xenophobic rant
toward a mexican dude at a show who was
offended by one of his jokes
told him uh had the whole audience chant
usa usa
usa said some [ __ ] like if you don't
want to be here if you're going to
support another country get the [ __ ] out
that's not a very tolerant guy these are
all very cancelable things they try to
cancel him
yeah he's just kind of neglecting all
that and the people that are rushing to
celebrate him bother me more i love cat
williams people that are rushing to
celebrate him bother me more because
it's like oh now he's your hero
because he said one thing you agreed
with maybe he's acknowledging it maybe
he's like yo when i had all these people
chanting usa
i actually [ __ ] up he could have
brought it up that's a great time to say
you know what
i [ __ ] up and he did apologize and i
don't have a problem with cat my bigger
problem is with the people
celebrating this guy now he's your hero
and we just ignore
all the other [ __ ] exactly yeah i don't
think he's
uh i don't think he's been in a position
to like deal with canceled culture
like cat's been forgiven for a lot of
his transgressions because people are
like oh that's cat being cat he's crazy
he's on
drugs or he's doing something he's got a
tumor or whatever the [ __ ] he has had
some sort of medical issues right so i
think a lot of people just let him
do whatever so he hasn't really
experienced it because the expectation
for him is so much higher
right um but i also think this is a
little bit of like just being a comedian
like
we like to have the unique takes [ __ ]
that nobody else is saying yeah and the
unique take on canceled culture right
now is
that it's good or you shouldn't complain
about it because
the unanimous decision now with even
within politics is
cancelled culture has gone too far right
like everybody believes cancer culture
has gone too far
so in order to have your own little hot
take you're gonna have to say
you shouldn't and um i don't think that
he wants to write jokes differently
i think if you ask cat i think he's a
purist he just wants to say the funny
things that he thinks are funny
but he's making the argument for
changing his material he's saying
you don't lower the basketball rim you
don't do whatever and so okay katsu now
you're not going to use certain words
that you used to
use before like now you're going to
change what you think is funny according
to
what the internet believes is okay to
joke about i know that he wouldn't do
that
so i know that he's not capable of
living his raps if you will
yeah so i think that this is more about
like having a hot take instead of
actually feeling this way
and when he puts out more stand up he's
incredibly prolific cat like yeah so
when he puts out more standup we're
going to see
and the standup is all of a sudden clean
and he's going along with whatever
twitter says is okay to say and not
using any
uh you know derogatory terms not being
sexist bigoted
uh you know homophobic racist at all in
any of his jokes
then we'll go okay you you believe it i
have a feeling that's not going to be
the case
um yeah no i i but time will tell
yeah scientific yeah i don't i don't
necessarily disagree with what he said
though i do think that like a lot of the
cancer culture conversation is like kind
of blown out of proportion
and if you look at like actual comedians
that are like canceled for jokes like
there's not a ton
and like most people that are canceled
are like for actual bat [ __ ] yeah cosby
or whatever like
it's typically i find like for actual
bad things it's more it's less like
um it's more the fear of cancellation
that i think
people are are concerned with and that
inhibits the creative process
so it's like how often does it really
happen maybe not that much
but things only need to happen a couple
times for it to create a fear
like the fear of getting into like uh
you know being in the water and getting
eaten by a shark is way more prominent
than the actual occurrence
sure right so we we often
dictate our behavior based on the fear
right not how likely it will be
yeah and i think that's what a lot of
like creatives comics think about
they're like oh i'd like to do this joke
but like what if it get that gets out
there and i get
canceled and i lose my sponsorship and
all i say okay i won't do the show
so now they can't create in this free
environment right right and
cat is created for himself to his credit
a career where he can create quite
freely kind of like what we've done
and right just to slice what you're
saying you're not saying someone that
wants to do like an outright like racist
or hateful joke you're talking about
someone that wants to do a joke that is
like
edgy yeah but they might not be canceled
for it but they're like i don't want to
run the risk
yeah exactly and the joke could be
inherently racist because it's a joke
but not that's not because of how you
actually believe right but the joke
itself is racist or it's sexist or
bigoted in some way right but ultimately
it's a joke but it's just a joke
you're not saying it because you feel
that way you're saying it because that
thing said is funny
right yeah i think that's a good
distinction and i i tend to agree that
there are some people that are doing
just offensive stuff and it's kind of
lazy because it's not
trying to be offensive it's just i mean
trying to be funny just trying to shock
you with defensiveness
i find that a bit corny but i still
don't think you should be
um i crucified for that yeah you [ __ ]
up man do better
yeah that's the that's the thing the
audiences will decide like if enough
people support that kind of humor then
you'll have that kind of humor and
you'll have that kind of audience and
you'll be fine
that's fair too and uh but just the idea
of like the ability to go out there and
create
without being concerned yes i think is
important for us
it is so hard to be creative every
obstacle that comes in here
i'm that much more in my head i'm that
much less funny yeah
yeah i will say one thing that i didn't
like about his comment and that i
disagree with is that
he makes i think a false equivocation
between like sports and cancer culture
yeah where he goes there's you know
there's boundaries for a reason there's
a speed limit for reason and
my thing is like yeah but those things
are decided upon by a governing body
like there's the nba or there's the
government that comes together and says
yo this is how these rules are going to
operate and everyone
that is in our jurisdiction is going to
operate under those rules yeah whereas
with cancellation and like the mob
quote-unquote on the internet
a lot of times it's dictated by like
academia it's dictated by like
random people on twitter like there's no
consistency or coherence
it's just like uh you know whatever the
movement is on the internet so like
if everyone was under the same rules
like okay we're not gonna trash
politicians in this way
then it's like all right cool but if
it's like oh you can only trash
conservative politicians in this way
then there's some inconsistencies and
then there's inconsistency and so to me
it's like oh there's something that's
that's happening that's not like what he
we have boundaries too like our boundary
is funny like if it's not funny it's out
of bounds
yeah right so the second it's not funny
everybody just goes hey buddy regardless
if i agree with the politics or not
the joke wasn't funny enough yeah and
you're not canceled for that but
effectively you are
if you only tell unfunny jokes nobody
wants to see you and then you have a
career right
you've canceled yourself yeah so i think
that that does already exist but i think
he's misconstruing what's really going
on
right and i don't chalk it up to to
ignorance because cat's like a really
smart guy
and the guy will read the guy will dig
into it like i'm sure he's abundantly
uh you know it's abundantly clear to him
what cancer culture is i don't think
he's just like riffing
right he knows what it is he's aware and
he knows all the controversy around it
and he's choosing to have this take but
it is what it is
you